Islam truth. How you doing? What's going
on, brother? How you doing? What's up,
man? You think Islam is reliable? Of
course, Islam is always reliable. Islam
to hear, man. That's what I like to
hear. Would you think a religion is
reliable if it has corrupted scripture?
Uh, unlike Christianity. You said what?
Unlike Christianity, unlike the Bible,
Bible's very unreliable. So, if so, if a
religion has corrupted scripture, then
Can I finish? I thought you didn't. As I
was saying, No, no, I didn't finish.
Okay. So, so the question you didn't
Hello. Hello. I'm there. You can you can
hear me, right? Good. Yeah. Yeah, we
good. Okay. I asked a specific question.
I didn't ask for you to ramble on. I
asked the specific question just like
how you ramble on reliable if it has
corrupted text. Unreliable with if it
has corrupted text, of course. Okay. Is
the Torah in in Islamic text? The Torah
and Islamic the Torah that was revealed.
Yes. Not not the Torah that we have now.
Was the Torah corrupted? Yes. All right.
So, the Torah was corrupted. The Was
that an Islamic text? The Injil Islamic
text? Yes. Was it corrupted? Yes. All
right. The Torah and the Injil Islamic
texts, they were corrupted. What about
the Zub? The Psalms. Was that corrupted?
Not sure about that, but I don't think
so. So, the Psalms is good. The Psalms
is intact. No, I don't I don't know. I
don't know about that, though. Why not?
Um, sorry. My uh again, I don't know if
I said this before, but I'm not a
scholar. I'm just a lame. You guys all
say that. Trust me, it's okay. So, how
how do you know that the Torah and the
Gospel are corrupted, but you don't know
about the Psalms? So, I study the I
study the Bible. I have like a bunch of
Do you know what I'm thinking? So,
you're a scholar of the Bible? Not a
scholar of the Bible. I am a um I'm a I
study. I studied. That's okay. So you
studied and so you know that the Torah
and the Gospel are corrupted but not the
Psalms. You don't know if the Psalms is
corrupted. I I think I think they are. I
mean all all together is that the Bible
itself is corrupted. So all right got
it. So the Psalms is corrupted too.
Throw that in there. All right. So the
Torah Islamic text corrupted. The Zapor
the Psalms Islamic text corrupted. The
Injil Islamic text the gospel Islamic
text corrupted. Yep. So Islam has three
scriptures that have been corrupted.
So then Islam is not reliable. Islam is
reliable. You just said that a religion
that has corrupted scriptures is not
reliable. One second. One second. You
trying to twist my words? Twist it me.
One second. One second. You trying to
twist my words? Let me cook. As you
said, Islam is reliable and all this
stuff. I know. As you said, Islam is
reliable and is reliable. Crazy. Okay.
Torah and
Islam Islam standard is the Quran. The
Psalms is corrupted too. Throw that in
there. All right. So the Torah Islamic
text corrupted. Zapor the Islamic text
corrupted too. So then Islam is not
reliable. Islam is reliable. So then
so you're a scholar of the Bible. I
don't know if I said this before but I'm
not a scholar.
In the NGO is right. So, okay. Ask a
specific question. All right. So, I'm
about to play you. I'm going just check
if this is you first. So, hold on. Um,
you can you can unmute your mic. All
right. Okay. I don't know why you muted
me that much. Oh, because I just needed
you to be quiet while I was trying to
play something for a second. You just
kept talking. Um, and so I'm about to
I'm about to put this on the screen
here. Okay. I'mma play the voice. You
tell me if this is you or not.
Unreliable if it has corrupted text.
Unreliable with it. If it has corrupted
text, of course. Is that you? I think
so. Maybe. So, so you said that if a
religion has corrupted texts, then of
course it's unreliable, right? Yep.
Exactly. Okay. Very similar. Islam has
three texts that have been corrupted,
right? Mhm. So then that means No, no,
no. Hold on, hold on, hold on. Sorry,
sorry, sorry. No. Oh, no. No. But you
said you said earlier that No, no. In
reality, in reality, those are for
Christianity and Judaism. But but hold
on. You said that those were Islamic
texts. the original forms and then they
got corrupted, right? There are Islamic
texts that have got that have gotten
corrupted, right? No. So look, I So look
look one second. Let me explain. I'm
confused. I'm a little confused. I'm not
going to lie. Yes. You might have said
Islamic text and all this. The Islamic
text. No, not me. You you asked me about
Islamic text, right? And you said yes.
Okay. Okay, that's fine. So look, I'm
going to explain it what I meant. What I
meant by Islamic text is the original
form. The original form has been
corrupted. And those original forms are
now attributed to who? Judaism and
Christianity. But hold on. These are
Islamic texts though, right? And they
have been attributed
to which are No, hold on. Does does the
Quran attribute that to outside the
Quran? The Quran attributes the Torah,
the and the Zabur differently from
Islam. Show me there. Show me that
verse. Okay. For example, it says um it
talks about I don't know the exact
verse, but it says that you have the
where you studied. I believe the
Christians they have Jesus Jesus
revealed Jesus was revealed for him.
Mhm. The injil okay that's one. And
Jesus now is attributed to three gods
which are Is that was that in Islam?
Jesus is Muslim. But okay. So is that in
Islam? No. So Jesus didn't believe in
Islam. Jesus is Muslim. But Jesus does
not believe in the Trinity. I'm going to
ask you one last time cuz it sounds like
you're not okay. Okay. Okay. Listen.
Listen. Was Jesus in Islam?
Was Jesus in Islam in the Quran? Yes.
Thank you. Beautiful. And in the Quran,
Jesus, an Islamic prophet was preaching
the Injil Islamic revelation. Right.
Correct. And this Islamic revelation,
the Injil ended up getting corrupted.
Right. That's exactly what I've been
saying the whole time. Okay. So, Islam
has a corrupted text, the Injil. Same
with the Torah that got corrupted.
Different different is different. You're
changing it around. So the injil and the
Torah in the original and the uh in the
original form is the correct text that
is not corrupted. Got it. And that is
the one second. And that is one second.
Can I finish? Can I finish? You didn't
finish form. Let me finish. Can I
finish? Can I finish? Yeah. Go. Go
ahead. I'm sorry. Okay. Thank Watch your
head on the way out as you finish. Zack,
you're on stage. Hello. How you doing,
man? You think uh Islam is reliable?
Yeah, I think Islam is reliable. Um, but
first up, first off,
um, she logic. Uh, how do you know like
I could be your god right now? So, do
you want to do any tests to make sure
that I'm not your god before you
continue this conversation? Is a
religion that has corrupted scripture
reliable? Hold up. Are you sure you
don't want to check if I'm your god
first? Because then you should change
uh, you might want to change your whole
kind of demeanor during this
conversation if I'm your god. Is a
religion that has corrupted text
reliable? Can you hear me? Am I still
on? All right, man. Muslims, man. I'm
telling you, we are having the biggest
weirdos from this religion. The biggest
weirdos from this religion, man. I've
never experienced such a mental
collapse. I'm telling you. I'm telling
you, man. There's a there's a there's
something, you know, you could be wrong,
right? You can have a you could be wrong
about something, but to be mentally
unstable is another thing. It's another
thing. And so I I I'm telling you, it's
Islam and it's the letter community.
Y'all are like right there when it comes
to mental, you know, unsteness, mental
like tarted readation. You know what I'm
saying? Just weird. Y'all are weird
people. All right. Good evening. Good
evening. You're a Muslim? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, I am. You believe that Islam is
reliable? Do I believe what? You believe
that Islam is a reliable religion? Yeah,
basically it is. Do you think that a
religion is reliable if it has corrupted
scripture? I don't subscribe to Islam as
a religion. I believe it's a kind of um
system of judgment like a way of life.
I'm sorry, say that again. Like I don't
subscribe to the religion definition
like Islam is a religion on like I'm a
Muslim so I don't subscribe to the whole
sectarian thing. Okay. So it it so you
don't you don't say that Islam is a
religion at all? N I don't use that
because the what is Islam to you? It's
more of like a belief system like a
system of judgment. You know the
religion is n if you read kafiron um the
usage of um dean is not in line of
religion. Are you only Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Sure. You don't follow any hadith. I
don't I don't do that. Say that again. I
don't do that. I don't follow any. And
why is that? I came into Islam through
um the Quran. So it will be a big
injustice on me if I accept the date
because I had my criterion of why I
believe the Quran is true. So me trying
to force myself to resonate with the
date, it's actually me being insincere
to the text. So that's why I actually
don't subscribe to it. Do you believe
that the hadith go against the Quran?
Yeah, sure. though they deny that but
it's evident that it goes against Quran.
Yeah. Okay. That's that's interesting.
So you would say that uh would you say
that the ones who follow hadith that
they're misguided? Cuz it seems like
they kind of put the Hadith over the
Quran in some instances, huh? Yeah, they
they do actually though they they deny
that. They deny it. But they do actually
because whenever you tell them the Quran
says this they I have to go to know the
scholars say this or that say this or
prophet M said this. So they giving
theelcept any kind of justification they
want to. So I really don't try to argue
on that aspect because they will call us
um disbelievers which is funny. Yeah
that's crazy. Like I got Muslims right
now on TikTok in the comment section.
And some of them are saying you're not a
Muslim. I would say that you're more of
a Muslim than they are cuz you actually
read the Quran. That's the funnest part
because whatever they do that and most
of them don't actually like understand
what they are reciting which is which is
a word. You call yourself a Muslim but I
don't know if you're reading the Quran
back to God. God gave you the Quran but
you're reading it back to him and you
don't even understand what you're
reciting. It's kind of it's kind of
weird. Yeah, I feel that. I feel I feel
what you're saying. I feel your
position. So you believe that uh so you
don't subscribe to the idea that Islam
is a religion per se but you would grant
that Islam is a belief system. Would you
agree with that? Yeah. Yeah. I I agree
with that. It's kind of a belief system
just talks about psychology and things
like that. Okay. And you believe that it
is a um a reliable belief system. Sure.
Sure. Sure. 100%. All right. And so my
question like I've been asking the
previous guests um is a belief system
that has corrupted scripture would that
belief system be reliable if it has
corrupted scripture? Surely it wouldn't
100% it wouldn't be it shouldn't be
reliable at all. Not reliable at all.
Right. Yeah. Okay. And so then well I
mean you're you're Quran only so I this
will be interesting to ask you. Do you
hold that the Torah and the Gospel have
been corrupted? corrupt the okay let me
define why I won't say corrupted
basically but I'll say um the decree
which means um the members of God as
being what is being taken out from the
Torah and the text actually be um true
to itself but you know when you read the
testament you find more of history of
the Israelite the old thing and stuff
when you read the Bible I see the Bible
new testament it's more about Jesus and
everything so I believe the decree the
remembrance of God on his own is what
has been taken out from this text. So I
say it's corrupted but we just say the
remeance of God
is the Quran it says God with the decree
as he says to preserve the Quran the
decree existed before the Quran was been
compilated.
So that's what has been preserved or is
been lost in those scriptures not like
the text. So I don't know if I lose
corrupted or don't know if you get what
I'm trying to say. If I understand
correctly, I I tried my best. Okay. It
It sounds like you're saying that the
text is not corrupted, right? The text
is the same. It's preserved. Um Yes. How
it was written. Yeah. But I guess you
say I heard you say something about the
decree of God. No, not decree. I think
my Arabic is not that fluent. Decree. D
I K R. Decree means the remembrance of
God in Arabic. Oh. So the verse that the
Muslim use that
to subscribe to the Quran is being
preserved. The verse does not say the
Quran is being preserved. It says the
decree will be guided. Right. Right.
Right. Right. Right. Oh, you're saying
the vicor the reminder. Yeah. The
reminder. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. 15 verse9 100%. So you're saying
that when it says that Allah will
protect and preserve the reminder that
holds true for all of his revelations,
all of his books. Basically for the
Quran, I won't I won't go I won't
stretch it to say for other scriptures
basically. I won't stretch it. I don't
make conclusion on that. But I will say
basically on the Quran. So but because
when I read the other scriptures um it's
alluded to different like um remeance
like okay when I read the testament I'm
more saying about the history of
Israel culture and everything when I
read new testament is all about Jesus
this Jesus did that. So the reminder of
God basically like being focusing on God
basically is not really embedded into
those scriptures. So it's kind of
confirmed to me when God say you will
preserve the decree the reminder in the
Quran because whenever you read the
Quran in fact you can't even subscribe
it to because you can see m mentioned in
the Quran in
fact in the translation you see them
putting that bracket mhammmed just you
believe that Jesus do you believe that
Jesus was crucified I I believe people
will actually think that because God
says it appear to them so I believe
people will believe that kind of
concept. So I don't think that is up for
disagreement if people believe such. No,
but I mean like what what do you what do
you hold to? Do you believe he was or or
not? No. No. Since I believe in the
Quran, I believe he was taken up. I
don't believe he was crucified. Okay. So
when I read in the gospel that Jesus was
crucified, but the Quran says he wasn't.
What do I do with that? How do I Yeah.
If you're true to the Quran based on
this text, it says it appeared to them.
So it won't be their fault basically to
write it down like oh he's being
crucified since that's what they
actually saw but God is clarifying that
he was not crucified. So I don't know
whoever my point is is that you have in
the in you have God saying that Jesus
was crucified in the Quran you have God
saying that he wasn't. So how what do I
do there? The gospel you're referring to
people said he was crucified. I don't
think there's where God said he was
crucified. Oh yeah. I don't know. It's
God. It's God's word, right? That's what
this is what God revealed the the
gospel. No. Okay. This is it. I don't
believe every any text came in in form
of being written. You get um the Quran
basically there's a verse where Allah
says um that if the Quran has come down
in a written form even says this is pure
magic. So the Quran didn't form a form
of what is it called a written text. It
was more oral. It says the Torah and the
gospel were written though. Yeah, it to
be written by people but the uh what was
it called the transl I mean the
revelation basically to be more or so
people can write it down and Allah has
given the um previous people the what's
called the tax to guide it but I think
they failed. They didn't like guide the
So you believe so you believe they they
messed up the NGO? Yeah, I believe they
inserted into it their own belief system
into it. Okay. And how do you how do you
know that? Like what how do you know
that? Just reading the text on his own.
Yeah. What where what in the what about
the text is like oh Jesus didn't
actually say this when he says like for
example um the son of man is going to be
given over to the chief priests and be
crucified and die and rise again on the
third day. When Jesus says that are
you're saying that he never said that? I
I won't say he never said that because
maybe he felt like he would be crucified
or he would be killed. So I I won't say
he didn't say that. He might actually
said that because he might feel like
these people are going to kill him. So
he didn't so if he did if he didn't if
he if that actually didn't happen then
Jesus lied. No, he's actually human
basically. So he can project that
something will happen and it didn't
happen. God said he saved him. So it's
not like um Jesus is trying to it's not
how I call it. It's not a battle between
him and God. He might felt like, "Oh,
this thing will happen to me." Then God
saved him at the last point. All right.
Well, it was interesting talking to you,
man. I appreciate you coming up. All
right. Thank you so much.